hello everybody I hope that you're good
I hope that the audio is better um a
follower told me to buy a sponge and put
the microphone of these earphones inside
the sponge and I think it's working
better guys let me know uh can't believe
about a sponge anyway if you guys
remember we we talking about this week
okay the week got fil here the 50% this
is the one hour time frame okay we're
want to talk about this now but the we
got filed the 50% then it went to the
150 Ma at this moment Bitcoin was quite
stable cuz it didn't want to drop really
low tested as resistance and then
continue dropping so at this point it
was quite stable then it went again
towards this zone of the of the 50% of
the week and what you see here guys is
what I've talked in the previous video
okay you have consolidation around the
50% of the weak area and that is telling
you that you haven't seen a strong
reaction from this because if you wanted
to see um a drop from here a full
retrace then what you would have uh seen
is a drop like this well like this then
retest the 50 ma continue dropping okay
if you don't see that and you see price
instead goes back again to the 50% of
the week Zone okay if you notice would
then hit it by just uh $50 and then we
were consolidating here that is telling
you that there is an intention to
continue pushing price higher towards
the 100% of the week okay so that was a
signal telling that price was going to
go higher towards the 100% of the week
and and and fill the whole week okay now
today quite an interesting day because I
didn't expect this move uh in the
session okay this uh this pump um I
always wait for Asia to do its job and
then I start to analyze things in the
London cem so um when I saw the Ia was
pumping I thought okay it's going to be
a good day for trading um usually when
Asia um pums then it's a good trade for
trading for me so that was the first
thing then when we were in this one I
posted on Twitter I guess most of you
follow me on Twitter but let's go to the
15 minutes time frame I was telling
you that I was quite likely that we saw
a spike above 30,000 because if you
notice uh that was the the previous week
okay and I was talking about this idea
okay the possibility of a sweep of the
highs and I'll tell you why I got to
this idea and it's basically because I
was trying to think about the most
manipulative move they could do we've
seen in the other book this week in on
Twitter again how they were spoofing the
area of
29,900 there was a lot of orders there
also at 30,000 because there is always a
lot of orders around numbers but there
was also a lot of orders at 29,900 and
through the week we were seeing how they
were slowly removing some orders and
today suddenly they removed all of them
and they didn't add them to 30,000 so uh
that was simply uh spoofing and they did
that when we were around
29,800 so at that moment that's telling
you okay manipulation is going to take
the control of the charts again and also
we were looking at the liquidation um
hit map there was a lot of uh long
liquidations so you mean the only way to
to add more liquidations to that is to
make a new high that's the idea of the
sweep of the high okay that's what I was
thinking about this projection because
with this projection what what you are
doing
is anybody that had the idea of trading
the breakout because many Traders uh
what they trade is um when there is a
new high they go long and when there is
a new low they go they go short so
imagine how many how many Traders here
went long okay after they so 30,000
getting taken all right so that's why I
thought about this idea and then as s
retrace uh pretty much you can see if
you go to the 1 hour time frame you can
see here that this was a $500 candle
$520 uh candle in one hour okay so
that's a very sharp retrace towards the
15 m in the 15 minutes time frame okay
now how do I trade this I was telling
you guys on Twitter look at this
momentum okay there is a lot of momentum
look at these candles okay there is qu
of momentum the momentum really didn't
uh cool down any time so that's what I
was telling you that it was not a good
idea to place any limit order here and
instead what you should be doing is to
look for that Swift in momentum okay how
do you do that okay you mark the 30,000
level that's the yellow line and you can
see how they sweep the highs that's the
stop hunt and then if you notice what
the next candles are doing is testing
that level as resistance okay so you've
got really from 10:30 UTC time until
1:30 you got 1 hour they you the
opportunity to short with a high prob
trade for 1 hour you go to the 1 hour
time frame what do you see guys okay let
me remove this you see a long week
what's going to happen to that week it
gets 50% filled and then it drops
another opportunity so you've got there
two confirmations to the idea that there
was going to be a um a recovery of this
Zone okay a chance to to go short and
then a hyper trade towards the 50 main
the 50 minutes time frame so um use this
video as an example because um this
price action is very common you're going
to see this quite a lot and the only way
to to get to this conclusion is um
either either by learning from somebody
else or by watching the charts for for
many hours and seeing this type of price
action happening all the time okay now
what do I think that it might happen in
the New York session to be honest it's
quite difficult to tell this was the
main trade of the day uh that I took um
I took the full profits at the uh 50 EMA
in the 15 minutes time frame so right
now um I don't have any position open
okay and the reason is because it's
Friday the weekend is around the corner
um I usually don't like to have any
positions open during the weekend and I
recommend you um to do the same so um I
don't really know if we're going to
continue dropping in the New York
session okay if that happens then I want
the same as I was telling you in the
previous video okay now with the in the
15 minutes time frame I want a a big
drop test it as resistance the 50 m and
then continue dropping okay where to
well you're going to go to the next area
which is going to be um the 50 ma
because there was here some resistance
also you have this one over here so all
this one here should be could be support
and also you have the one or
50ma okay so that's the next area if I
should if I'm given the opportunity what
I would take profits now in my opinion
and this is quite a bold statement I
think it makes more sense okay to not do
that move today again I I may completely
wrong because there is there are also a
lot of long C liation still but in my
opinion it makes more sense either to
consolidate in this zone
or to recover this large um red candle
and then consolidate in this one so
that's why I've taken all the profits
from my short at the 50 m okay because I
think that that might have been the uh
the short opportunity of the day so
maybe recovering this this large candle
is more likely or or um you mean just um
consolidating it at these levels okay
but it's true that I see uh more
potential downside over the next days
again probably I'm thinking now next
week but we're want to see because you
know New York is usually when most of
the volatility comes
in and again if I
given if they give me this
opportunity then uh that's a another
short idea all right so I hope that was
clear now we're going to go into the
liquidation levels we're also going to
check the liquidation hit maps and see
what is going on
there let's check the liquidation levels
and we can see what 20 billion worth of
long liquidations okay right at the top
there was $23 billion so you can see how
um def liquidated $3 billion but they
still got that $20 billion and that's
quite a lot and the only thing that um
could justify a push higher is that we
got here qual of liquidations at
30,300 and also at
30,500 um so that's what I'm telling you
um I'm not sure if I want to continue
seeing u a drop during the New York
session that's why I'm at the moment
quite neutral right now I've got the sh
that I want it um I'm thinking that it
would make more sense to continue
consolidating during the rest of the day
and during the weekend and then uh
probably these liquidations will go down
to maybe $15 million or so and next week
is when we might see a stop hunt up and
then a big drop okay but again um the
new station is only going to start now
so it's difficult to tell that's just uh
kind of like a quick thought also
something that really gets my attention
here is the ratio of short liquidations
versus long liquidations it's huge okay
total short liquidations 118 total long
liquidations 8003 that's a huge ratio a
huge difference okay so I telling you
the long positions are a risk that's
what I also said this morning in in the
in that tweet before that move um during
the London session so be careful uh with
Longs that's why I'm not thinking at all
about opening Longs here even if you are
at the 15 minutes is uh time frame 50 mm
now what's going on with the liquidation
hit marks let's have a look 12 hours
time
frame okay I see that there is a Jello
bar at
28850 um it's quite low let me check if
that
was the 50 ma in the one hour time
frame yes it is it's at
so okay that's quite interesting level
that might tell you that yeah there is a
possibility of continue dropping today
so uh pay attention to the 15 minutes
time frame because maybe it giv us a new
uh short opportunity there towards that
level okay that's quite interesting 7
Days time
frame nothing really going on you can
see how yesterday they hit uh the level
we were talking about
29,400 and right
now it's quite neutral at the moment
okay I see a lot of liquidations growing
here but I don't still see any specific
level just um kind of like a like a big
uh Zone here so nothing that catches my
my eyes and the one month time frame is
showing liquidation to the downside but
they are quite far away so for day
trading we can't really use them right
now okay we can only use the liquidation
scene big time frame when high time
frame when we are close to them okay so
for example at this level in this Z then
you you could tell it was quite likely
that we drop towards this on B right at
the moment having the Liquidations in
the one month time frame so far away it
doesn't make much sense to use them as
uh for day trading and that's why I'm
not going to go into the three months
and six months uh that's perhaps for
another video of a high time frame uh
perspective but that's pretty much
everything that I'm that I'm seeing
today the the most important thing is
that um I think I've updated you on
Twitter pretty well today and with this
video I just really wanted to to talk
through um more specifically what I what
I saw in price in the price action um to
get to that projection so that that you
could use that um education and also um
little idea for the New York session um
potential uh consolidation
okay or even a recovery of that large
red candle around
29,900 okay that's what I'm right now
out of my shorts that short is finished
for me but if we see a drop below the 50
50 minutes time frame then I retrace to
test it a resistance then I'll open a
new short okay but for now I see that
less likely so that's pretty much
everything guys and before I finish the
video I wanted to mention that uh We've
added new courses to the website in case
you want to continue uh learning the
whole trading system um here we talk uh
in in detail about the week fill
strategy the liquidity pools the
behavior of
candlesticks the timing about the
trading sessions or the psychological
pattern of the week so there is quite of
to learn and we have here some courses
so far the next course that is the 30th
of October the two groups are fully
booked but we still have some spots
available for November okay so that's
pretty much everything guys thank you so
much for watching and I'll see you soon